can you take me through a perfect day in
the life of akara Nakamura on on a day
of a big chess match
multiple days right we'll take one where
it's a big chess match and one that's
just like your representative average
day a perfect Chess Day although I
cannot do this uh it would start like
the night before I would get like nine
hours of sleep uh like a consistent nine
hours like say 12 a.m to 9am for example
let's just say the round starts at like
two o'clock and then nine to say 12
o'clock I do preparation and then 12 to
1 I go eat lunch and a one to two I just
nap or I walk or I do something
completely unrelated to it that would be
the perfect day
when are you doing uh everything except
the preparation are you thinking about
Chess at all are you trying not to think
I'm trying not to think about Chess
definitely not what do you do is there
any tricks to that well I find that like
if I go outside I just try to try to
hear like the birds I try to listen it's
one of those like meditation kind of
things like you know they always say
when you meditate you try to try to hear
yourself breathing it's like when you
close your eyes try to hear yourself
breathing just focus on that so I do try
to do things like that uh from time to
time as well so in terms of getting nine
hours of sleep that that come difficult
to you that almost never happens I mean
there have been a couple times where it
has happened like in Norway specifically
but generally it just I don't sleep well
during trust terms I wish I did but
but so we're talking about a perfect day
so sleep is really important what about
diet and stuff like that yeah I think uh
for a lot of people they try to keep it
light before the round actually like I
remember hearing the story from uh Peter
sevidler some years back a Russian GM
and he said that kaspara would go and
eat like a big steak right before the
game and he would he would be completely
fine but I think for most players it's
the exact opposite you try to like eat
like some snacks like maybe some nuts a
few bars things of this nature or maybe
just like maybe fish something very
light for lunch
um before the game and then then you
probably eat a lot after the game that's
generally what you try to do but I don't
think there's any like specific diet
that makes a huge difference but every
everyone is different of course so when
you're actually at the board
on that perfect day how do you maintain
Focus for so many hours of classical
chess like like
um you know what like minute to minute
second to Second how are you able to
maintain focus is there tricks to that
how difficult is that I think it really
depends on the type of the game that
you're playing I think if it's a game
that's very very calm and very slow or
not a lot happens at the start it's a
it's a lot easier because you because
you're not having to be super focused
like your mind can drift and and whatnot
and the critical moment you have to sort
of Zone in
um so those are the easiest ones I think
generally when when games are very
complicated from the start uh what
you're doing is you're you're just
you're you're trying to not let your
mind wander at all because when games
are complicated like that one of the
things that I've never been very good at
is my mind does wander and you're always
like I'm always worrying about the next
move it's like is this a blunder what's
what's going on like what am I gonna do
um so you're trying I think very much to
block out the noise I think that's
actually the hardest thing is is also
because like I can say this when I
played Magnus before there have been
times when I've gotten winning positions
against him and in that moment when I
have the winning position very often
times my mind wanders like okay you're
about to win this game you're like okay
what happens after the game you win this
game gain the rating points all these
different things but you haven't
actually won the game yet and I think
for a lot of players that's the hardest
thing is when you get a winning position
your mind does drift it drifts to like
what the what happens after after you've
won the game or what the outcome is so
yeah drifting into the future and you
should stay in the moment you really
should yeah like hold on and also
what is it uh yeah probably getting
excited about the win what what is that
what is it about that that makes you
worse at playing
so interesting like getting uh well I
think it's you you get it's like a nerve
it's nervous but it's like you're you're
too excited I think you just you it's
like you're waiting for a time you
expect it to end and then and then your
opponent keeps keeps defending and and
you can make mistakes what about the
flip side of that where you start
getting frustrated like how do you try
to recover from that kind of thing it's
very difficult I I think for myself I
just try I try to basically focus on it
every single move I just try and again
you try to block out the noise no matter
which direction it's going in so I try
as best I can I mean sometimes I'm very
poor at it like I just don't do a good
job uh blocking out the noise at all but
I think generally I try to think okay
just make this next move make your
opponent have to find the best moves and
just just keep the game going no matter
what just keep it going by the way
what's a long day of classical chess
what's that look like this it's pretty
brutal I mean it would be something like
okay so the game starts at two o'clock
so you've done all this other stuff the
game probably goes from like two to
seven for example or maybe two to eight
five six hours probably eat uh you eat
dinner for an hour or so maybe clear
like I'll go clear my head for 30
minutes and then immediately it's right
back to studying for a couple of hours
are you reviewing previous games are you
already uh generally you're just moving
on to the next game that's what you're
not and trying to no matter what
happened put that behind you yeah win or
lose or draw
okay so that's that's also why there's
another question a lot of people wonder
which is why don't I play more of these
classical tournaments and
sort of it gets back to the you know the
literally don't care Source stuff but
when I'm going to play in tournaments I
want to be able to give it my best shot
and if I don't feel that I can I'm not
going to play which is why like I play
here and there but I do balance my
schedule very carefully because I'm not
just going to go and play tournament
simply because if I don't feel that I
can put in the work uh it's not it's not
it's not the right thing to do also
because I'm taking away a spot from
somebody else who probably will be
putting in the work who will want to
compete in that event and so when I look
at the candidates or a lot of people say
well why why is he playing there like
okay qualified but he's not going to
take it seriously
um but I did give it everything I had in
that tournament
um and I always will as much as I can if
I can't do that then I'm just not going
to play
so what about a perfect day in the life
of vacara when you're not doing a
perfect day a perfect day would be
something along the lines of I get up
very early like three four o'clock in
the morning drive an hour away and go
climb mountains that's the perfect day
out in the mountains oh oh do you mean a
normal non yeah a perfectly productive
normal day oh perfectly productive okay
so perfectly productive would be along
the lines if I wake up at like 7 30 8
o'clock probably I watch either
Bloomberg or CNBC for 30 minutes to an
hour
um and then watch the markets for maybe
maybe an hour or two look at certain
things that are you really care about
investing uh I do follow it quite
closely yeah I follow the markets very
closely closer than I should but yes for
personal reasons so do do you comment on
it like do you like for personal
investing reasons or for like
philosophical understanding what's going
on in the world it's it's sort of
everything I think first of all
obviously I'm interested in investing I
have been for many many years I've done
investing trading for at least a decade
now
um so like I am very interested on that
level I'm also quite interested as well
because when you see the policy that's
being dictated like you look in the last
last six months specifically you see the
FED policy around things like interest
rates unemployment things of this nature
it is something that interests me also
because I do invest in real estate aside
from the stock market so therefore I'm
always keeping an eye on these sorts of
things and and always looking and as a
better example like I'm looking for
Trends so if we go back to I think it
was 20 I could have the year wrong it
was 2015 or 2016.
um there was a pattern that I found that
on the FED minutes that came out uh you
know I believe 2 215 I think it's on the
Wednesday of every well third Wednesday
of every month
um that gold would actually the gold
ETFs and etns would actually go up uh
not every single every single Wednesday
of the month that the minutes came out
so I would follow things like that now
of course I wasn't like trading huge
huge volume but I found a trend there of
course it stopped working at a certain
point but those are the sorts of things
they just interest me even if it's not
something I'm doing to make a living
trying to spot those Trends it's always
been something that has uh that has
fascinated me
one Reddit said that you shorted Tesla
some time ago uh do you regret doing so
uh well when I when I did those plays I
was only those small amounts of money
and that was only via uh via puts that
was where I would buy puts or put
spreads um on it so it wasn't something
where I straight shorting I would I
would never actually do that
um because it's just it's not worth the
risk and I don't want to ever be in a
situation where I have to think about
those sorts of things and I think a
better example is there was a period in
2016 actually shortly before the
candidates when I actually was in oil I
had a long position in oil and this is
when oil completely crashed it went very
I don't think it went below did it go
below 30 even it went very low and and
of course the Saudis were not cutting
they were not um I think they they were
uh was were they cutting or not cutting
production but anyway there was a period
in 2016 when I had a big long position
in one of the 3x oil ETFs and I I it
kept going down day after day after day
and then of course right near the bottom
I find finally couldn't take it anymore
I took a loss and that really sort of it
was very difficult dealing with that the
stress every day looking seeing those
losses and after that I kind of decided
I would never put myself in such a
situation again
um and so that's why like I don't I
don't do shorting and then separately
and I think I post a reply to this
comment but in 2021 as Tesla started
going up I actually started selling puts
and I did quite well off of that so it's
it's sort of play Both Sides never never
like become hard set with your
conviction like where you refuse like
this is this is just like it has to go
down or like it it has to go up just
sure you'd be you have to be um willing
to adapt if you think shorting should as
should be legal do you think it's
ethical like to me I'm not I don't know
much about investing but I feel like it
feels wrong now I know
if uh something is over inflated
it's good for there to be an opposing
Force to like balance it or something
like that but it just feels like in our
current modern internet world I think
Tesla I vaguely saw somewhere that's
like the most shorted stock like ever
and so that incentivizes a lot of
um the publication of misinformation
about it like it just feels like the
incentives are wrong not when we look at
the markets but at the future of human
civilization perspective it just feels
like shorting is somehow wrong but maybe
maybe I'm misunderstanding the broader
picture of markets well I actually try
not to do that I like I almost only take
long positions specifically because I
feel like you're at betting betting like
on world collapsing I just I feel like
morally I don't want to be in that that
I don't I don't want to have that
Viewpoint I think you know that sort of
is another thing that I've noticed like
I've been very lucky I've traveled a lot
I've met a lot of a lot of famous people
and the one thing that I've known
notices like a lot of a lot of the
people who are the most successful
they're the ones who are very optimistic
no matter what is happening day to day
they remain very optimistic about the
future of where things are going
um so so I try not to enter in that
situation I think as far as like
shorting specifically the real danger to
me is that anybody can now invest and I
feel like actually some of these apps
like Robinhood they go out of their way
to try and make it seem like it's this
fun game
um like I I I've seen people where you
place a trade and like it gives you like
like these stickers or these pop-ups
like of confetti and it's like wait a
second what what's what's going on here
um with the whole with the whole game
like people are sort of they're going
after the wrong thing
um so I I don't think shorting like will
be banned but I think it's very
dangerous that everybody has access to
to being able to do things like that so
according to Reddit on the topic of
Tesla
uh you have trouble admitting when you
make a mistake is that true
um no that's that's generally not true
actually I think that way Reddit is not
100
accurate and truthful in his
representation of a character that's
fascinating no I think I think the thing
that I I've learned is I'm obviously
very good at chess but that doesn't
automatically mean that I'm I'm a genius
and everything else and I feel like
that's another thing actually I really
really admire about Magnus is that he is
the world champion he's the best player
but he does not automatically believe
that translate to EV translates to every
area of life I feel like with some other
world champions they think that they're
great no matter what they do
um and that's not not like intentionally
trying to be like be like rude but I do
feel like there's certain people who
feel like that like anything they say is
right and they are the authority
um when in reality like we are the
authorities when it comes to chess like
we know trust the best we are the
experts but that doesn't automatically
mean we're Geniuses and everything else
that said I think you said somewhere on
the c squared podcast that
I forget if it's chess or streaming that
taught you to generalize to various like
you feel like you're able to do other
things now was that streaming I don't
know if that's specifically streaming
but I think streaming has taught me a
lot about sort of life and also how to
run run a business honestly like I've I
have read a lot of business books and
one of the things with streaming is that
when you start out it's like this very
small thing it's just you maybe you have
a couple of people who help you along
the way but as it becomes bigger or
bigger if there's a boom you suddenly
start having to hire employees you're
basically running this business and like
for me I've I've learned a lot about
that because one one of there was this
book that I read some years back I think
it was by Mary Buffett it was on Warren
Buffett and and how like he tries to be
hands off like when he buys these
companies it's hands-off management
stays the same you don't do anything and
I actually I try to do things kind of
the same way where like I try to be
hands off there are a couple people
around me I leave a lot of the general
day-to-day decisions up to them and then
like things that are really important
obviously I'm involved in but I try to
do things like that so streaming is you
learn a lot along the way and I think
now having done that there probably are
several other potential careers that I
that I could have if I really wanted to